je pense qu'il est important de dire aux
effort que les femmes dans les conflits
armés ont des droits que ces droites
tiennent compte de leurs besoins
spécifiques et que donc il existe un
cadre juridique contraignant obligatoire
tant pour les belligérants je vais y
revenir dans un instant que pour
l'ensemble des États qui sont d'ailleurs
partis aux Conventions de Genève on
pourrait penser que cela va sans dire
mais je crois que ça va mieux en le
disant et cela permet ensuite de mieux
répondre aux questions que vous vous
posez sur l'établissement des
responsabilités la recherche des
responsables et aussi la question des
réparations
je veux donc dire qu'on ne part pas de
rien on parle de disposition qui existe
et depuis longtemps et je pense aussi
que le droit international humanitaire
en période de confirmer comme d'autres
normes comme le droit international des
droits de l'homme le droit des réfugiés
un peu évoqué tout à l'heure
répondre en fait de façon plutôt
adéquate je l'ai dit au besoin des
femmes qui se trouvent dans ces
situations
autrement dit le défi
consiste à
traduire le droit en pratique par divers
moyens et lorsque le droit n'est pas
respecté donc à mettre en jeu les
responsabilités et donc
si à travailler énormément à la
prévention bien sûr des violences là je
ne parle pas de la prévention des
conflits armés comme le sénateur tout à
l'heure parce que ça va beaucoup plus
loin mais en tous les cas il y a tout un
travail pour prévenir les violences et
je m'empresse de dire que cela aussi est
une obligation endroit international
humanitaire et la prévention c'est aussi
on en a parlé un peu tout à l'heure
c'est modifier les comportements c'est
comprendre l'origine de ces
comportements et à cet égard le CICR a
travaillé sur ces questions et à publier
différentes brochures sur les
comportements des et les origines de ce
comportement des belligérant